do you think Snoop did this in La where
he had met with the sheriff the L.A
County Sheriff to try to help kind of
bridge the gap between like maybe some
of the misunderstandings between the
police and the community and obviously
it's a very
rough place when the cops ain't from the
community you know you I always feel
like when there's community policing
where it's like yo this is where I'm
from I live I grew up here whatever
there's a lot more understanding there's
a lot more compassion
um will that ever be something you'd be
interested in doing like maybe trying to
help assist like the police not assist
them to like arrest people but assist
them and understand it hell yeah yeah
that's important to me bro because we
need police if something happened to my
mom machine from the call nobody but the
[ __ ] police right we need police bro
I agree we need responsible police but
we need police responsibilities we need
police that's in the city that
understand we know your name [ __ ] your
mama live right here she here she good
like that's how it used to be and they
could get to that because I'm I come
from a foundation bro I used to I
listened to my old my mama stories my
daddy stories oh his stories were like
the whole neighbor I used to when I was
growing up they say the whole
neighborhood could whip your ass you did
something the neighbor beating your ass
right here you finna get your ass beat
right here in front of this house for
doing something I got I dare you uh
neighbors know your mama ain't trying to
come touch on these kids man gonna get
your ass shot yeah I'm gonna happen
right it was different back then my mom
and them said the neighbors used to be
able to beat their ass and tell yeah he
did this told a mama she thank you and
then you're gonna ask me about it yeah
yeah I guarantee you somebody off the
neighborhood they know your mama go try
to run up on the left man they go if
they don't they gonna beat your ass yeah
they need to get back to that
you used to get the Govern our
neighborhood control our neighborhood
police our neighborhood secure our
neighborhoods that's the only way it's
gonna be safe for us because at the end
of the day we the only neighborhoods
that don't do it the white neighborhoods
do it the Irish the Jewish the whatever
the Arab every all these communities do
it you know what I'm saying and I admire
that there's no way that I could ever be
a racist because I admired a way that
people stick together we need that you
feel I'm saying we need that for
ourselves I could never even think about
another culture and how they look at us
because they look at us like y'all crazy
as hell right y'all don't give a [ __ ]
about each other how the [ __ ] we gonna
care about y'all
it's impossible we gotta care about each
other first ain't nobody gonna give a
[ __ ] about us we don't care about each
other why why should they yeah I mean I
ain't gonna give a [ __ ] about a [ __ ]
that don't care about itself like I said
I know you can't help everybody so if
I'm trying to do this and a [ __ ] ain't
trying to help itself and get no money
what the [ __ ] I'm fixing to still try to
give you some money for
as a as a black man that's how we think
so how the [ __ ] you think somebody on
the outside looking what the [ __ ] I'm
helping them for they ain't doing
nothing but killing each other
it's the same thing bro universal law is
the same no matter how you look at it
bro we got to think about universal law
and principle that's the only way we're
gonna get better yeah man I mean I think
a lot of people in your position should
preach that yeah but all right bro I
just I just grew bro I'm just a grown
man I look at life totally different bro
cause I got [ __ ] that I care about you
got yeah you got children hey man I feel
like once you have kids man you take
that father [ __ ] seriously through
everything serious bro I can't I can't
lose I can't lose in no way I can't lose